et avait 78 nous sommes toujours en
plein tour du monde à vélo mais un arrêt
s'est imposé puisqu'il ya un confinement
qui a été mis en place
ici donc au pérou et halima
particulièrement où nous sommes un
confinement depuis le 16 mars avec un
couvre-feu de 20h à 5h du matin nous
sommes donc en confinement chez un ami
jean georges que nous remercions
énormément pour son aide donc une
situation un peu particulière pour nous
qui avons l'habitude de voyager chaque
jour dans un nouvel endroit une nouvelle
ville nouveau village au pérou faut
savoir qu'il ya actuellement environ 395
cas pour cinq décès et il faut savoir
que le confinement a été mis en place à
peu près à 100 cas on sent que le
péruvien et les habitants du pérou sont
très sensibles à cette problématique
d'autant plus qu'ici services de santé
sont beaucoup moins développé que dans
des pays comme comme chez nous comme en
france donc on sent que ils font vite
concernant ce qui va venir donc du coup
ont tous les jours on apprendre de
nouvelles choses ici à lima et on parle
d'un prolongement deux semaines et un
mois
ce qui est intéressant de remarquer du
coup on est dans une capitale et c'est
comme à paris il ya beaucoup de bruit et
beaucoup de pollution on se rend compte
qu'il ya beaucoup moins de circulation
on sent que l'air est beaucoup plus pur
on va dire d'autant plus qu'on est à
côté de la mer du coup nous ce qu'on
espère toute l'équipe est grosse et
qu'on puisse se s'engager tous ensemble
aussi vite que ce confinement ce que ce
problème sanitaire pour l'environnement
je voulais bien évidemment remercier
toute l'équipe de tbs 60,18 qui
travaillent en ces jours de confinement
je n'oublie pas les monteurs ni même
l'infographiste merci beaucoup et puis
bah bientôt on espère au tour du monde
ciao